Democrats in the media gang-rape Brett
Kavanaugh president Trump gives a
wonderful and hilarious press conference
then glenn beck stops by and finally the
mailbag
i'm michael Knowles and this is the
michael Knowles oh oh what a day what a
day
first of all welcome to my boudoir I
know that you I often bring you into my
boudoir on different ads I'm here
obviously in Pittsburgh I'm giving a
speech tonight at Franciscan University
of Steubenville and if you're if you're
in the neighborhood you know if you're
walking around Steubenville stop on by
were to be talking about the simple joys
of being right so I'm on the road we
have so much to talk about I have been
glued to my screen all morning watching
the stupidest miscarriage of justice
that I have seen since Anita Hill and I
was only one year old when Anita Hill
happens so real is a real nice refresher
before we get to any of that let's make
a little money honey how's that sound
and actually let's talk about your money
Robin Hood is a new sponsor and we love
new sponsors and it's a sponsor that
will make make all of us more money in
in the sense that you can invest your
money so Robin Hood is an investing app
that lets you buy and sell stocks ETFs
options Kryptos all commission-free they
strive to make Financial Services work
for everyone not just the wealthy simple
and intuitive clear design and data
presented in an easy design way I really
like it I should clarify if you it's not
that it will make you money you got to
make the money but Robin Hood makes it
easy to do I really like it there are no
cost no commission fees other brokerages
charge up to 10 bucks for every trade
but Robin Hood does not charge
commission fees you can trade stocks and
keep all of your profits you can learn
it by doing a lot of Millennials are
really stupid when it comes to
investments in vet invest your money
don't be a dummy I mean you've got to
make your money work for you Robin Hood
is giving listeners a free stock this is
pretty good a free stock like Apple Ford
or sprint to help build your portfolio
sign up at Knoll scanner wles
Robin Hood dot-com do it you know I've
had sort of providential financial
success largely through the writing of
blank books follow my lead
go to Knowles Keo wles Robinhood dot-com
it is terrific and and I think you'll
really enjoy it okay so we got to get
right into the news today if you haven't
been watching lucky you
oh lucky you if you've missed out on
some of the stupidest hearings ever it
is so Christine Blasi Ford testified
before the Senate today the Judiciary
Committee Brett Kavanaugh is set to
testify though I think that either
that's happening right now or that's
about to happen I have not seen it yet
what have we had some since last we
spoke we have now had people coming out
this new woman
Julie sweat Nick accusing Brett
Kavanaugh milk-toast Federalist judge
Brett Kavanaugh of participating in gang
rapes of facilitating gang rape Brett
Kavanaugh oh oh by the way this woman
this new accuser her ex-boyfriend filed
a restraining order against her
apparently she's a total Looney tune her
lawyer is Michael avenatti so we know
that she's a Looney tune
she's sued her previous employer for
sexual harassment using the law firm run
by Deborah Katz who is also the lawyer
for Christine Ford are you catching a
theme here or you are you sensing a
pattern all these people seem to be
connected I watched all of that all of
those testimonies earlier Christine Ford
I saw a point-by-point
I won't subject you to the clips but
it's a total circus the one thing that's
come out of this which is really
shocking is that we're actually seeing
Lindsey Graham be just a hard-line bad
mf'er you know I mean this guy is really
like a Lindsey pulled through on the
leather jacket you know got the brass
knuckles on here is a Senator Lindsey
Graham reacting to Kristine Ford's
testimony today they say that she wasn't
sure we were willing to go out there
that's a bunch of bull I don't know what
they told miss Ford but we were willing
to go to California we were told she
couldn't fly all I can say is it were 40
something days away from the election
and their goal not miss Ford's goal is
to lay this past the midterms so they
can win the Senate and never allow Trump
to fill the
see I believe that now more than ever I
don't know who paid for a polygraph but
somebody did and here's what I'm I'm
more convinced up the friends on the
other side set it up to be just the way
it is
I feel ambushed as the majority we're
gonna hear from mr. Kavanagh judge
Cavanaugh and I've been a judge
prosecutor and the defense attorney and
here's what I'll tell you when it comes
to where it happened
I still don't know I don't know when it
happened she said she's a hundred
percent certain it did happen I bet you
judge Cavanaugh say I'm a hundred
percent sure I didn't do it the people
name say they don't know what miss
Ford's talking about she can't tell us
how she got home and how she got there
and that's the facts I'm left with a
nice lady who has come forward to tell a
hard story that son corroborated and
this is enough god help anybody else
that gets nominated based on what I
heard today you could not get a search
warrant or an arrest warrant because you
don't know the location you don't know
the time and you don't have any
corroboration yeah you give it to him
Lindsey you Bulldog Bulldog Lindsey
Graham here he is he's absolutely right
from the beginning of her testimony
onward she got there she said she sat
down she said you know after my opening
statement I anticipate I'm gonna need a
little caffeine so we're probably gonna
have to break well if you anticipated
that why didn't you bring a cup of
coffee with you or better yet have a cup
of coffee before you sat down is it
because you want the television coverage
to only cover your statement and not
cover up any of those pesky questions is
that what happened she's asked these
questions her story has been changing
the Senate Judiciary Committee appointed
a prosecutor to ask these questions
because none of the men want to seem
like they're angry and asking her
questions so they got this nice-looking
woman to ask the questions instead she's
changed her story Christine Ford at
various points she's you know I don't
know what happened to her I didn't
something might have happened maybe
something didn't happen but from this
testimony we cannot conclude that any of
this is credible I'll explain to you
exactly why and why everyone believing
her is really
acting out of a misguided passion before
I do that though come on
it's it we're talking about sex you're
in my bedroom you're in my hotel room
let's talk about purple mattress I love
purple mattress purple mattress has
fixed an important aspect of my life you
know that I sleep 17 18 hours a day I
really care about what I'm sleeping on
purple mattress is unlike any other
mattress that you have ever tried that
has ever been invented it's not like the
spring is it's not like the memory foam
I've tried both this is better this is a
zillion times better if you're
struggling to get a good night's sleep
try purple mattress purple mattress it
was invented by an actual rocket
scientist it's designed by actual rocket
scientists and you know I am easily
satisfied by the best I'm a man of
simple tastes this is so good you get a
hundred night risk-free trial if you're
not fully satisfied to return the
mattress for a full refund
backed by 10-year warranty free shipping
and returns feel what it's like to sleep
in my bed feel with that I'm gonna get
me tuned for the I'm gonna get called
before the Senate Judiciary Committee
for this go you're gonna love purple go
you'll get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's an
addition to all the other great gifts
they have it seriously this bed is
unbelievable go do it it is worth the
money
it is 100% worth the money it's always
worth the money to have a good bed but
especially this one
purple comp promo code cough FA CoV fe
fa purple dot-com promo code cough fa ce
o-- v fe fe the only way to get this
free pillow is to use my promo code you
know what it is co v fe fe @ purple com
it is not credible these allegations
that she's making are not credible why
Lindsey Graham said it she didn't tell
us the year she can't tell us how she
got there she can't tell us how she left
she can't really tell us where it was
she can't tell us the circumstances the
people that she's named as having been
there say they weren't there they say
that Brett can all wasn't there
there is no corroborating evidence now
what the Democrats are trying to do is
make a circus out of this and say well
there was another accusation they said
yeah but that other accusation was from
some total wackadoodle whose boyfriend
got a restraining order right on her
yeah but it was another one it's with
all these accusations you know I mean
you know accusations right I mean that
no I don't know what or any of the
accusations credible well no but no but
there's so many of them yeah but they're
all if I so if one crazy person tells me
that you know the sky is about to rain
down purple donuts and and then for
other crazy people tell me the same
thing that doesn't mean this guy is
gonna rain down purple donuts it means
you've got a lot of unsubstantiated
claims that was an analogy I made on the
fly I don't know how much it totally
olds up but it doesn't mean that it just
because you have a lot of people saying
something you need evidence to back that
up by the way there were a few really
important moments here the prosecutor
asked her said did you give your medical
record the medical record of you talking
about this assault the diary entry from
the therapist did you give that to the
Washington Post and she and the lawyer
jumps in he said all you don't know
don't answer that you don't have to
answer that don't know it but no no she
says well I don't I don't know I don't
said what you mean you don't know so it
turns out that Christine Ford's
short-term memory is as bad as her
long-term memory because it's not like
asking her what you had for lunch a
dozen days ago or two weeks ago
it's asking her the only piece of even
quasi evidence sort of resembling
evidence that you have that when you
were talking to the Washington Post did
you hand that to them it's just I I
don't know that was less than eight
weeks ago that she would have done that
you don't remember less than two months
ago really really smells fishy I don't
know what she thinks I don't know what
she thinks happened or if she's mistaken
or if she's lying or worried even if it
really did happen but we have no
evidence for it and what these people
like mazie Hirono the senator or the
democrat senator from Hawaii what
they're saying is he's guilty until
proven innocent and a lot of people now
are saying it's he's too tarnished he's
not too tired you're trying to tarnish
him but he's not too tarnished and by
the way I got to tell you something I
was watching this on CNN this morning
because I'm at a hotel room you know so
I got CNN look if I watched CNN I
probably would believe that this guy is
like a super Nazi rapist killer I would
I actually empathize now cuz I had to
watch CNN I empathize with a lot of
America if you were getting your news
from CNN they had a whole panel and all
they did after every little bit of
testimony they would just go one by one
Jake Tapper whoever the other people are
say oh well very credible testimony oh
yes it was very credible it was you know
thing that struck me about it the
credibility of a credible credible
credible credible credible grandma
didn't seem credible to me didn't
present any evidence she contradicted
herself several times she actually
admitted to changing aspects of her
story she appears to have contradicted
the guy who gave her the polygraph test
she wouldn't answer questions about who
she's met with we know the lawyer comes
from Dianne Feinstein we know it stinks
to high heaven credible credible
credible credible give me a break
and I got to tell you these moments I
you know I wish we're gonna run out of
time but I do I think Donald Trump
explained this very very well because
you've got these guys like Jeff Flake
who's saying well we need to hear them
out I won't vote I these kind of fake
squishy vichy Republicans but he had
this great line in this press conference
outside the UN where he talked about
George Washington he compared the the
treatment of brick havena to the
countrymen George Washington would get a
fewer and we were up for a job these
days here he is look if we brought
George Washington here and we said we
have George Washington the Democrats
would vote against him just so you
understand and he may have had a bad
past who knows you know he may have had
some I think accusations made didn't he
have a couple of things in his past
George Washington would be voted against
100% by Schumer and the con artists I
mean 100% 100% so it really doesn't
matter from their standpoint that's why
when John asked about the FBI
if the FBI did the most thorough
investigation in the history of the FBI
and they found him to be 100% perfect he
would lose every single vote now if the
Republicans win tomorrow I think you're
gonna get some votes from the Democrats
you know why because we all know why cuz
it's called politics then you'll
probably get so much there it is the
honesty of the Donald he's gonna he says
you know what it is it's politics that's
what it is we've got one other excellent
point that he made because this press
conference was the answer to his UN
speech he gave this stately incredible
erudite sophisticated UN speech
obviously was totally missed reported in
the media so then he has to do what
Trump does which is give this wacky zany
I think was an
one minute or 80 in 981 minute press
conference where he goes all colorful
and then he gets all of the coverage
again but there were some really great
moments to it before we get to that I
one more baby one more we're gonna make
a little bit more money okay we're gonna
thank software advice this will help you
to if you've ever started a business if
you're in a small business running your
own working for a small business you
need software advice lowercase letters
and uppercase letters it costs you time
it costs you money when you don't know
the right software solutions and and by
the way you could make the wrong choice
and that will cost you a lot of money
don't do it when you're dealing with a
real head-scratcher having your go to
person on call is a no-brainer you've
got to use software advice their team of
advisers will point you in the right
direction that you can start working
more effectively right away its software
advice.com slash knowles KO wles you
answer a few sort short questions about
your business whether your medical
professional construction manager HR pro
whatever any small business you if this
will work whatever your jet whatever
your business is if you're an
entrepreneur you work solo it's a great
way to get an expert opinion they are on
call it's your go-to team and you can
figure out your business software needs
for free it's totally free start there
and the software struggle today go to
software advice.com slash knowles kano
wles so for advice that comes lash
knowles kano wles to connect with an
advisor for free what's that address you
know it by now
software advice.com slash knowles
this last bit Trump was asked his
opinion on what's going on with Brett
Kavanaugh today and a lot of other you
know like the Diane Feinstein Kamala
Harris Cory Booker you know ridiculous
types would would play it up really
sanctimoniously
cory booker right now is questioning
questioning the girl Christine Ford and
they all the Democrats are opening their
testimony they say I just want you to
know this isn't a trial and I just want
you to know I believe you I believe you
and they all do it because they all all
this thing is about is getting clips for
them for their 2020 campaign and clips
for the midterm ads that they're gonna
run on it Donald Trump because he's a
more honest broker than these guys he
just goes right for it here is President
Trump on the hearings I could only say
that
what they've done to this man is
incredible I think when you really look
at it all it's not going to change any
of the Democrats Minds they're
obstructionists they're actually con
artists because they know how quality
this man is and they've destroyed a
man's reputation and they want to
destroy it even more and I think people
are gonna see that in the midterms what
they've done to this family what they've
done to these children these beautiful
children of his and what they've done to
his wife and they know it's a big fat
con job and they go into a room and I
guarantee you they laugh like hell at
what they pulled off on you and on the
public they laugh like hell people are
gonna have to make a decision 36 years
there's no charge all of a sudden the
hearings are over and the rumors start
coming out and then you have this other
con artist avenatti come out with
another beauty today he's got another
beauty today I love it I mean this this
is the Donald Trump that I think really
resonates if you showed the American
people you say okay a woman who for 36
years never mentioned anything can't
recall any of the details of the event
all the other people that were allegedly
there deny it men and women you know the
guy's been a federal judge forever six
FBI investigations now all of a sudden
this comes out what do you believe that
or do you have Donald Trump's take it's
a con job it's obvious it's transparent
obviously it's gonna be the latter we
got to get to clinic you know I've got
Glenn Beck coming by for an interview is
gonna come to my hotel room no I'm just
kidding he's not cut that would be that
would be so weird I could meat to him
for that I we hung out with Glenn Beck
back around the studio and man he told
us he told me some stuff I actually did
not know about him and had not heard
going back 20 years so it's pretty cool
definitely check it out and we'll be
right back after that with the mailbag
Glenn thank you for being here really
all right thank you you know I have to
tell you I only did that because I've
been here all week and Michael I don't
know if you know this but they treat you
like garbage they do they do I you
didn't want to feel left out
well no I mean it's just a habit you
know hanging around with Ben
he just trashes you personally my family
yeah I looks yeah I know yeah I was
caught why I was wondering I figured now
would be a good opportunity how's it
looking at the blaze we wouldn't he said
he was gonna call ice on you though yeah
yeah I mean you know why he's got the
Ben debt you know well you you can
understand this because you and I are
authors yeah we're a best-selling author
right all right it's because I wrote
this book this best-selling book he's
been very writing is really very much
you're very lucid really clear no it's
good it's good yeah it's pithy that's
what I like about it's just it gets
right to the heart of it brevity is the
soul of wit and they're from I'm the
wittiest guy that was 200 some pages
it's very brief now you you have also
come out with a book you made a
different choice though as you put words
in I put words I put words in mine
addicted to outrage I actually wrote
this book twice not literally
I wrote it the first time and I learned
so much while I was writing it that by
the time I got to the end I was like
okay that that's all that right that's
that's too elementary Wow and so I went
back and I rewrote the entire book which
was a little brutal was it was it just
your thinking that changed your process
or was it something about the news or
the face no it's it's my thing you know
it's been really strange because when I
left Fox that was on a prompting I mean
I went to I went to Billy Graham and
talked to him about it and Billy Graham
said I said I'm leaving
Fox and I wanted to talk to you about it
and he said that sounds like something I
would do if I were the adversary
convinced you to leave Fox and I said
well I don't think it was I think it's
prompting from Lordan he said tell me
about it and so we sat and talked we
were supposed to spend about 20 minutes
we know spending about five
hours together and he in the end agreed
with me and my thinking but I knew that
I had done my best
mm-hm and I believed in what I said but
the country was spiraling out of control
and was that that's what convinced Billy
Graham to convince Billy Graham of
something that's that's it yeah I mean I
don't want to I don't want to you know
yeah but it was it was spiritual in
nature and it was about reconciliation
and he said you know reluctantly I like
okay I think you're right and because I
was very upset when that show I love
that show
I knew I had all the time it was so fun
it was on when I was in college we we
would insist on having your show on all
the time
Fox was on a lot but we would sit around
the TV in common yeah it was Rachel fun
yeah it was it scared the crap out of
Fox cuz it was it was ad lib right and
we would turn in a script every day and
they would pour over it and then I'd get
in and I'd say you turn off the
teleprompters and you know so they they
were just freaked out I had everybody
mean I had the I know cuz I know people
at the White House I had people at the
White House senior watching every
episode we had Media Matters watching
episode we had everyone watching every
episode going looking god what is he
gonna do what's he gonna do it's cousin
ray an early understanding of podcasts
right because when you go on to even if
I'll go on Fox & Friends for a three
second hit and everything bulleted its
laid out the Chiron's everything's
really set podcast though I mean we
don't have a script you'll night you
notice there's no no papers yeah and
it's and it was um you know it was just
speaking from the heart and just and
just laying it out and not caring you
know carrying it that we did a good job
in the
got it right but not him I mean if you
know what what I loved about that show
and all of your work is it wasn't it
wasn't talking points it you would bring
in history you would bring in what
everything and and you had fun with it I
mean it was a dirty word for
conservatives or it shouldn't when when
September 11th happened I had no idea I
mean I had just signed a deal with with
premier and but I wasn't national yet
and I was supposed to start January 2002
excuse me and I had just signed the deal
in August and and what I was doing was a
parody of talk radio it wasn't serious
okay most people don't know this but I
mean I used to you know I used to do 40
40 nights on the road with comedy and
and so when September 11th happened they
called me and said we need you on the
air now nationally and honestly Michael
I spent I spent about three days solid
beforehand on my nice going I'm the
wrong guy Lord what am i doing I know
why are you making me do this I don't
know any of this stuff okay I mean I
paid attention somewhat you know when I
was in New York and at WABC in 98 or 99
I remember we bombed a not aspirin
factory I'm not sure what the date was
but Clinton built on this as he needed
to get Lewinsky out of the headlines
that's what everybody said and I caught
I was on the air that day and I had done
my homework yeah he was going after a
guy that nobody had ever heard of and I
started doing my research on him and I
said okay I know everybody thinks he's
trying to get but I want you to listen
to this guy and I read all of his words
and he was coming to New York and he was
gonna kill us and the phone's blew up
everybody's saying you're just loved
Clinton I'm like I don't like what are
you talking about and I met me yeah I
mean maybe I don't like Clinton no it's
not his policies I'm telling you he's
right on this one
and I remember saying on the air within
ten years in this city buildings bodies
and blood in the street and it'll have
this man's name on it I forgot about
that
until September 11th the name was Osama
bin Laden Wow
and all you have to do is take people
seriously and read so I had done some
but not really I mean somebody called me
up and said where do you stand on you
know the the Israelis and the
Palestinians oh no it's me I don't know
I mean far as I was concerned at that
time the whole thing could go into a
sinkhole they're never there never gonna
solve it we've been battling forever
I've got the answer I've got the answer
yeah just don't talk to each other yeah
so I had no idea and all of a sudden
this big burden of responsibility you
know Ezekiel 33 comes I think it's 33 37
33 where he says you know I will place
Watchmen on the on the towers and gates
and if that watchman sees trouble coming
and doesn't blow his trumpet the blood
on everyone that could have been rescued
is on his hands well that's millions for
me and if I really truly believed it I
had to say it so when I got to Fox I
wanted to say it as I knew that nobody
wanted to eat that cuz I had just gone
through 2008 right and man I lost
stations and money and everything else
because 2006 I was saying financial
crisis could collapse the entire comic
on ax me could collapse the european-cut
economy cuz this is all bogus I don't
even know how it works
and you know at the time I was up
reading about the freaking money supply
on a prompting I got so mad at god I'm
reading about the m1 m2 m3 money supply
and it's like 2006 and I'm in bed it's 3
o'clock and I'm reading this trying to
understand it and I
it might kind of have kind of an is real
you know relationship yeah yeah a
little-little struggle with him and I
remember I the book aside get off me
never gonna need this I don't know what
you're making me read this for and and
then the economy collapses and Barack
Obama gets in and Roger Ailes had been
yeah courting me for a while and I kept
saying no and I didn't want to do cable
news but I knew then that it was it was
kind of too divine to be that that
platform to be available right and so I
I signed a deal for two years and
decided to entertain the folk a spoonful
of sugar makes the medicine go down
that's and that point is I think it's
really lost on people and maybe it was
lost in to some people in the Fox
audience because if you go at if you use
a little human if you go out and have a
little I've been using a little cough FA
you know if you have a little bit of
that and then you get some eyeballs and
you get a real message as long as you
don't violate the principles my right my
problem was in some ways the press and
the fact that John Stewart now this is a
really delicate line that I don't see
there's a difference but I think others
do John Stewart did with a whole bunch
of writers what I was doing every day
for an hour right with one and it's just
the difference was I was on a news
channel he was on the comedy channel now
I contend if I did it on the comedy
channel they still wouldn't have been
okay with it well certainly there
wouldn't hired you often yeah right so
it doesn't matter but that's that was
the excuse that it was mocking you know
the news and in a way that's true I mean
you know when you know that an industry
it's it
literally if you look back when someone
comes to the inside and mocks it and
ridicules it from the inside it's over
right and I think I think I was the sign
that news is over it was oh and it
assured in this totally different world
I mean we are in a totally different
world now
no millennial I know has cable they
don't even pay for game no it is all
Internet it's all new media it's all
podcasts Netflix whatever streaming I'm
not doing any mainstream media for this
book you're not going on TV or he'll
some work out because you know what Joe
Rogan Joe Rogan to me was the I said
this a couple of weeks ago when Elon
Musk was on yeah and you know the stock
Marko's down now I I'm I put in my
calendar
roken Elon Musk I don't want to miss it
right hey and you brought that that
great little bong the other day yes I
don't know what you're talking about but
so he's on with Rogen and the stock
market goes down yeah and I'll bet you
60% of the people in the media industry
had no idea and a good portion of that
didn't even know who Joe Rogan was and a
portion of that didn't know what a
podcast was they're just so arrogant out
of touch it's over it's over that's
right
that's so glam the you know you get
knocked for catastrophizing you get but
the trouble is that you're often write
about the catastrophes that you're
seeing so give me a happy note give me
something here
do you see happy do you think I'm an
optimistic catastrophist be good there
must be like a Gilbert and Sullivan song
this seems like a good thing to me the
new media at least this part the new
media allow conservatives especially to
get our message out there unvarnished
undistorted unpervaded you're you're
selling books on new media because
that's where the eyeballs are people are
tuning out of CNN there too so I
absolutely agree with you but it
requires us in it and I urge you to read
the books yes
yesterday look for it you will enjoy it
in because it talks about what's
happened to us why it's happened to us
and what's happening right now is the
the post modernists they are changing
they're changing everything because they
have since the Paris riots in the 60s
and 70s they realized they could not
take the Western world and destroy it
just through culture mm-hmm and they
learned it in the 60s so they came back
and they looked at post-modernism and
said okay how do we make this to destroy
the West entirely all of it
bring it down at the same time so then
you're free to start Marxism eroding
whatever you want some people see things
that never were and ask why not
why direct so if you if you understand
that then you can start to change your
argument because the more you throw it
back in anger the you're throwing
accelerant on the fire and I think
they're gonna scare a lot of people that
don't want to lose capitalism well you
know on the left to right I know a lot
of people that vote differently than me
that don't want to lose capitalism
pretty good it's been pretty darn sweet
the problem is we are up against the
clock now
I think our economy is it's a matter of
time before that comes apart I'm hoping
that it keeps lasting as long as it can
you have Russia nobody's paying
attention to a guy named Alexander Dugan
and everyone your age should be paying
attention to him because he is targeting
people like you and it's a very
dangerous philosophy you have the middle
east and worst of all you have tech you
have high tech which is starting a
timebomb in one and and also as they
start that time bomb they are gathering
more and more information which is more
and more power
information and knowledge is power and
and then doing strange things like
working with the Chinese who are
literally turning that into all that's
right yes 1984 it's you know it's
horrible what's coming there we have to
remain Americans remain calm find as
many like-minded people that want to
live in capitalism and freedom and
understand the Bill of Rights I don't
care who you voted for in the past I
don't care I don't care what you've done
in the past well unless your story your
oh yeah yeah well but but let's start
looking to the future and if we if we
hold together and we begin to talk about
the ethical uses of technology we're
going to enter a time that will be will
have freedom beyond any of our
expectations the world in the next ten
years is going to change so dramatically
that ten years from now you'll watch
this and it will feel like watching I
Love Lucy seriously well that that is a
happy note to end on and it does remind
me that you are truly the master
broadcaster because that is the greatest
possible segue I have ever heard for the
ethical use of technology to go over and
subscribe at daily wired.com and thank
you very much for being here q and one
Shapiro you she driving out of town on a
rail oh he's going to do well then I'll
heat up out of Texas not only telling
you this is a friend of yours and his
what he says privately about you is it
is profane pornographic oath over I I
say to him you're Orthodox or Emily and
he just goes off and I didn't even know
that was a word yeah that mental or
telling me I bet you bet in the privacy
of our own yeah I mean we're not on the
air now where we know what no I'm here
that's right you seen that you know what
Glenn thanks for being thank you all
right I'll see you every city
all right Glen get out of my hotel room
so I have that whole time that we've
been airing that I have been watching
the live testimony of judge Cavanaugh it
was stunning I we came for the drama we
got the drama I will be going over some
immediate reactions to that right now it
was really something else before we do
the plus we're in have the mail back by
the way we're gonna have to fit a lot of
that in maybe we'll have to do a little
mailbag tomorrow but before we do that I
have got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube sorry guys go to daily wire if
you were dealing wire calm thank you
very much you helped us keep the lights
on you keep qoph fa in my cup usually
right now I've just got like a hotel
room coffee but usually I have a leftist
ears tumblr which is really what you
need to sign up for you get all the
shows bench bureau and replevin me you
get to ask questions the mailbag blah
blah blah blah you're gonna need the
leftist ears tumblr for when judge
Kavanagh gets confirmed to the Supreme
Court go to daily wire calm we'll be
right back
okay okay so we've got some immediate
reactions to this I had it on the TV is
right over here
I was watching that live testimony Judge
Cavanaugh there was some debate among
analysts earlier is Cavanaugh going to
come and you know be very staid and
quiet and judicial let it go or is he
gonna bring it is he gonna defend his
reputation and fight back he fought back
oh my goodness he punched back he talked
about how unfair it was he he hit them
hard he brought it he had calendars from
the damn summer where did he find these
calendars that he talked about he said
oh my father kept all the calendars for
from like the 70s which is by the way
all our old nature's but aren't unknown
today a divine providential strike of
luck it it was really incredible and it
by the way it was convincing it was I
mean at this point if judge Cavanaugh is
lying this guy is one hell of a
psychopath it was he looked like a man
who was wrongly accused it looked like
the crucible you know John Proctor and
the crucible or something really it was
a stunning testimony I want to really
analyze this when we've got video
because it's still going on right now so
we're gonna get to that more tomorrow
but a stunning performance my takeaway
is all in all Christine Ford did fine
she didn't she didn't do bad she did
contradict herself a little bit she did
seem a little kind of one minute she was
kind of laughing and then the next she
was really serious and shaky voice it
was a little weird but it was fine
wasn't it actually wasn't bad she sort
of did well by her and her Democrat
friends but Cavanaugh did really really
well he did really well so obviously if
there's any justice in the world you
give it to Cavanaugh you can I mean
there's no no evidence at all he called
it he called the to sweat Nick
allegations that he was running a gang
rape syndicate he called it a force and
a joke it was really excellent excellent
stuff I'm gonna vote for this guy for
president I don't know what it is in the
last couple years the Republicans have
grown a backbone but I'm really pleased
to see it this is really good we can't
let them do this if we let them get rid
of
know who's left who goes up who goes up
to the Supreme Court the guy is
virtually perfect he's got this
unimpeachable record and if you can't
get him through who do you get through
it we can't let them do it really good
stuff okay we got to get to the mailbag
I probably only have about five minutes
left but c'est la vie we'll do it first
question from Madeline hi Michael I used
to identify with liberals in my college
days but my views have since swung to
the right since my mid-20s while I
strongly agree with almost everything
the left does I don't think that
everyone who identifies with the left is
a bad person I think many on the Left
are coming from a place of genuine
compassion for others with that said who
do you believe is strategically behind
the evil ideologies and policies they're
supported by the left yeah I don't think
that many or certainly not most and
probably even I don't think very many
lefties are bad people I think that
they're misguided or overly emotional or
wrongheaded GK Chesterton put it very
well when he was talking about his
friend George Bernard Shaw he said that
it's not that Shaw doesn't have a heart
he's got a very big heart it's just a
heart in the wrong place and I think
lefties hearts are in the wrong place
they're progressive so they're
progressing toward utopia the idea is
that mankind is perfectible
we're caught there's an obvious progress
that we're going toward and so therefore
if you stand in the way of progress if
you stand to thwart history yelling stop
if you're a conservative then you are
either very stupid or evil you have bad
intentions and for smart conservatives
for conservatives who can even string a
few words together it's not the former
so it has to be the latter that's why
they impugn our our ideas but they but
we don't really impugn or they impugn
our motives but we don't really impugn
their motives and so that's the ideology
I mean who's behind the ideology name
your pick karl marx nietzsche
i don't know it's bad ideas bad ideas
are behind it and you know the devil's
behind it when you trace bad ideas back
far enough you get to the devil but it's
i think it's caused by pride and it's no
coincidence that the left embraces pride
all over not just gay pride but all you
know fat pride didn't
racial pride not wipe right obviously
but other racial provides you know a lot
of pride and that's where it comes from
from Seth hi Michael I've been watching
the Cavanaugh confirmation process as
closely as most something's bothering me
clearly the Democrats are doing whatever
they can to delay his confirmation with
the hope of retaking the Senate November
stalling it indefinitely my question
isn't it hypocritical percent of
Republicans to contain a complaint about
these blatant political tactics
considering that in 2016 they they did
virtually the same thing in delaying
Merrick Garland's confirmation one thing
that has driven me crazy about the
modern American Left is its
inconsistency in ideology and approach
to issues
so when so-called conservatives have
engaged in similar behavior it's
troubling thanks and keep up the good
work thank you for the question Seth but
you are totally wrong I'm sorry to say
totally wrong yeah it's true Republicans
politically stalled Merrick Garland's
nomination we knew it we knew we could
do it we knew that the election was
going to decide it so we just stalled it
forever what we didn't do is call him a
rapist crime syndicate mobbed on who
just goes around raping women from 36
years ago we didn't do that at all we
just delayed it like civilized human
beings like people who aren't wicked
little hysterical child monsters but
what they have done what the left is
done here is based on nothing nothing
they have tried to ruin a good man's
reputation
with no evidence if they had any
evidence whatsoever if they had any
corroboration then maybe you could
consider it but there's no corroboration
there's nothing actually the people who
would be called under corroborated deny
that any of it ever happened that have
been called on by the accuser it's total
nonsense and it's really really wicked
and look if they had just said we're not
gonna we're not gonna confirm Cavanaugh
fine but they couldn't get away with
that because they don't have the votes I
mean that's what that's politics
politics is a bloodsport but what
they've done to this man is purely
wicked for how much more time do I have
I can probably one or two more right
from Samuel dear Michael I have a moral
question regarding hacking I've learned
a way to observe other people's network
activity via packet sniffing my question
is this is it moral to spy on another
person if they leave tear information on
protected to spy on their computer
searches I don't know is it moral to spy
on someone if they leave their bathroom
window open do you think that's moral
said you see a cute little girl in the
shower and you look through a window
what are you Brett Kavanaugh I'm kidding
I'm kidding it's a very heated subject
today it well it depends on what the
spying is if you're spying on some bad
guy to achieve a certain good who's
doing something illegitimate or
something criminal then I suppose it's
fine especially if you're a civil
authority but if you're just spying
because you're a little curious yeah
that's not fine at all it's no better
than being a peeping tom in someone's
bathroom window can I do one more I want
to do one more I'm gonna do one more
from Sean hello Michael
love the show I just had a question
regarding all of these claims of sex
allegations listening to people like you
been Andrew Matt Crowder and Levin
helped keep me sane I'm not the only
person wanting evidence I just want to
ask why colleges are canceling classes
and leftist mobs surrounding Ted Cruz
over allegations when these same people
are doing nothing over the allegations
of Keith Allison that has police reports
and medical evidence of his abuse of his
ex-girlfriend because they don't care
because they don't care about rape and
they don't care about sexual assault
they did this to George Will when he was
contradicting the reigning orthodoxy and
ideology about sexual abuse on college
campuses and they said you don't take it
seriously a bunch of idiot senators like
including what is Warren I think and his
response was perfectly right which is
that he said I think that I take sexual
assault much more seriously than you do
because he's unwilling to make a
political circus out of it because he's
unwilling to use it as a cudgel against
people that he happens not to like
because he's unwilling to use it as a
wedge to affect a certain political
agenda and that's exactly what these
Democrats are doing today it's
disgusting
it it offers no advantage or consolation
to victims of rape and sexual assault it
trivializes it they do this on campus
when they try to take sexual assault out
of courtrooms and put it into campus
tribunals obviously it tramples on the
rights of the accused the rights to due
process but it tramples on the it
diminishes the crime itself because rape
is a serious crime it should be taken
very seriously it should not be tried by
a bunch of bumbling professors or
daughter endemic
that's trying to angle themselves for
2020 campaigns in a kangaroo court
circus before the Senate Judiciary
Committee it's a real crime and it
should be taken seriously if you're not
gonna take it seriously that's my show
mo angry about these Cavanagh things I
will be tonight at the Kavanagh
at the Kavanagh at the Franciscan
University of Steubenville so we're
gonna be talking about the simple joys
of being right I'll be able to channel
all of my frustration into an
understanding of the joys of being
conservative and we got other speeches
coming up to October 24th October 25th
will release more information about that
soon in the meantime we're gonna have to
get two more mailbag tomorrow that's
just the way it is too bad
in the meantime I'm Michael knows this
is the michael whole show i'll see you
either tonight or tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018